so yesterday we played clips for you of
this absolutely ridiculous phone call
uh that donald trump made to the georgia
secretary of state
asking them to find 11 780 votes and
then saying come on guys i just need 11
000 votes to win georgia
and certainly that call is impeachable
donald trump should be impeached for
that he's not going to be i don't think
anyway he could be impeached after
leaving office but it doesn't seem that
there is a
political desire for impeachment but one
of the very
interesting things that has come out of
it is that georgia secretary of state
brad raffensberger who was on that call
he was the one being pressured and he is
a republican
being pressured to find a way to give
donald trump the state of georgia
he said it's unlikely we would
investigate uh or
or uh investigate criminally or ask
criminal charges to be brought
because we have a conflict of interest
we were involved in the call but it is
certainly something
criminal investigation and possibly even
charges that
an atlanta area district attorney could
do and this is once again
it's just the tip of the iceberg of what
we may see once donald trump is out of
office
and of course this should be
investigated here is the georgia
secretary
of state republican brad raffensberger
explaining
since he's involved in this he really
shouldn't be part of the investigation
and he's right about that
but says that there are others including
the atlanta area district attorney
that might be the right outfit to
investigate
david worley a democratic member of the
state election board which you chair has
asked you to
open an investigation into the call will
you open that investigation
i believe that because i had a
conversation with the president
also he had a conversation with our
chief investigator after we did the
signature
match audit of cobb county last week
there may be a conflict of interest i
understand that the fulton county
district attorney wants to look at it
maybe that's the appropriate venue for
it to go so the the first question and
we'll go through this sequentially the
first question is
what crimes might trump have committed
here
and it's actually a long list and i'm
not saying trump will face
charges i'm saying the list of possible
crimes
is long federal laws against
solicitation of election fraud i would
argue were broken
to prove it you need to know intent um
but and and that is hard to prove but
just because something can't be proven
in court doesn't mean that colloquially
speaking you and i can't say yeah trump
did that
uh federal laws against conspiracy to
intimidate
threaten injure or oppress any person
of rights secured by the constitution
georgia state law against solicitation
of election fraud arguably was broken
and georgia state law against willfully
tampering with an elector list
voter certificate ballot box voting
machine
tabulating equipment or to solicit
others
to commit such tampering so as i told
you before
with other trump investigations i don't
think this is going to go very far
but it may be yet another thorn in
trump's side once he leaves office
i think the most realistic scenario is
not trump ever gets perp walked in
handcuffs
not trump is even never criminally
charged with anything i think the most
likely scenario if i'm being just
you know not hyperbolic but but but sort
of conservative in my thinking with you
is there will be investigations into
trump
and his organization that will be a
thorn
in trump's side for years to come
now another interesting aspect of this
why was the call recorded to begin with
we know now that the georgia officials
on the call did the recording and they
did it because of their knowledge that
donald trump
previously has lied about the content of
phone calls
so the recording was almost like an
insurance policy for them
assuming trump would later lie about
what was said they wanted a record to be
able to say
here's what was actually said so it's
all completely embarrassing and
you know if only we could have seen this
coming right like if back in 2016
when when we were all sounding the alarm
and unfortunately there were some on the
left and right who were saying
it won't be that bad trump for four
years might even get us a true
progressive in 2020 that we would all be
happy with
trump will shake things up he'll sort of
bring a different approach
it has certainly been different there's
no doubt about that
but it has been an absolute and complete
disaster
regularly attacking in authoritarian
fashion
multiple endless aspects of our
democratic systems and
undoubtedly trump should be impeached
after the fact for this there's no
question whatsoever on the merits
whether he will or won't be i don't know
is it even worth doing
i mean listen as i said before there is
a duty to impeach
if you believe an impeachable action has
taken place
uh and we sort of have to separate the
potential outcome
which is not going to be very much from
from the duty to do what is right
as uh as congress is supposed to do but
i i at this point we're at a loss and
it's simply an emergency to get rid of
this guy we're down to 15 days
we are down to the last 15 days
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60 000 masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over 150 dollars you can
get there by going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david